do you have a question for me Allison I
know you are a history buff so I would
like to know what is your favorite uh
controversial historical figure Genghis
Khan Mussolini I don't know if you were
to become dictator with Limitless power
what would you do well first of all I'm
going to take the second question first
I know what it's like to be a dictator
yeah with Limitless power because I I'm
the host of a podcast with my name on it
uh every there's pictures of me all over
this building everyone has to do exactly
as I say it's fantastic everyone around
me will tell you that I would abuse my
power I would make people laugh at my
jokes I think I would pretty much I
think I'd become unhinged immediately
you know the way they say power corrupts
but it takes a little time with me would
happen immediately yeah I would complete
it would become unhinged do you art you
beat you beat some of the people who
work for you
you punch blay on a regular basis he's a
big guy he can take it yeah and they're
not allowed to punch back no no they
just take it yeah so yeah well that's
that really that's character building
for them I think
um so yeah I think I would lose it
controversial historical figures every
historical figure eventually is
controversial because over time anything
they've done so you could say Churchill
Winston Churchill in 19 you know you
could you could say that answer in 1950
and no one's going to have a problem
with you who means you know the big guys
like your stalins your Hitlers and
things like that well I am not on this
podcast gonna swear fealty to any of
those guys but you are pretty interested
in Stalin I've heard you Stalin's an
interesting guy yeah maybe interest is
yeah he's more interesting to me because
he was a Seminary Student you know and
he's also from Georgia which is a very I
mean to think that he climbed at the
very top when he came from a very a part
that many Russians don't even consider
to be Russia and was uh briefly a
Seminary Student I don't know I find him
to be kind of uh wacky but he did wacky
yeah but I mean uh you know a lot of
problems with that guy a lot of problems
and I know that's a controversial thing
to say but I find Stalin to be a little
problematic someone finally had the
balls someone finally had the balls to
say Stalin a little problematic and I
don't care we're taking your calls right
now call in right now if you agree wow
this board is lighting up how dare you
how dare you I knew Stalin someone was
my friend you sir are no Stalin